okay we'll see how long this takes
sometimes 10-minute chassis can
oh okay doesn't take too long
uh do i play a stafford i'll go for it
um
okay what a way to start the stream the
staff for gambit time
i mean this is a more like serious game
it's ten minutes
opponents from russia but opponents
thinking so that's a good sign
bishop e2 is met with this i want to
play knight g4
oh alexa quiet knight g4
that's my tea timer t is finished
brewing
i showed this in a recent youtube video
i showed d3 queen f6
um it was a fun youtube video is uh the
thumbnail was a mouse trap
oh h3 wait h3
h3 transposes into this line queen d4
and blocks winning
hey it's people welcome everyone
it took a few moments for people to
arrive
thank you oz materials let's go in let's
go let's go
let's go if you're just joining my
opponent has walked into
[Music]
one of my favorite if not like my
ultimate favorite
a staffer gamba traps
and i just lost slow motion replay i
just lost a knight
and a pawn however
i think this is completely winning i'm
just making sure
queen e5 bishop h3 i take looks very
promising
the problem for white is it's hard to
stop mate
if g3 i take because f pawn's pinned
and f4 is illegal because f pawn is
it's still pinned d4 doesn't help
i block my bishop and then i just mate
so this is really the only try and then
after it takes if takes i have queen g3
king h1 rook h3 mate
so welcome everyone good to see people
um very nice way to start the stream
opponent is realizing their doom
like as white i'm not sure what else to
consider maybe rookier
rook e1 then i can
queen h2 king f1 queen h1 king e2 force
a bomb cloud
and then bishop g4 f3 queen
g2 king d3 castling queen side with
check
is a fun line and then the kings drag
down even further
keep calculating there it's very close
to force mate
and corn on the cob welcome back gifting
a sub
to it's pants o'clock
oh we're gonna get this line this is a
rookie one line
let's go queen h2
yada yada i mean it's check check
check check at least
oh i might be winning the queen too
and like the very end because
skewer
oh it has two legal moves here this is
why i love the staffer gamut so much
good morning like white was trying to
play safe too
why play bishop e2 h3 and then like at
this point it's already losing
good morning or
is it afternoon somewhere maybe it's
afternoon in australia
or evening on australia i forget
okay so f3 now i forced
the king to
to my territory maybe um
i'm tempted to play wait a minute
i want to create a situation where i
castle queenside with mate
because that would be the ultimate
youtube content
but it's hard to construct because i
can't allow the knight to be here to
block
so i could play this
maybe i'll play this first
provoking92
and there's so many ways to win
it's like when you go to like an ice
cream shop so many
like different delicious looking flavors
and you can only choose one at a time i
could take the
pawn i could play this move look at this
move
because everything is kind of aligned
i'm still preserving my chance at castle
oh good morning yeah if you're just
waking up
i hope this serves as some form of
alternative caffeine so i'm threatening
to take the knight double check
wait that's i'm threatening maiden one i
wasn't made in one threat
um oh this is too much fun
okay let's calculate it might make sense
to take the
the knight first
because then i cut off the king and
after
queen takes i play b5 this is all
forcing
queen here king here here
it's gonna be made eventually oh there's
a funny mate where
the king takes my rook and then queen d8
in the end
let's do it oh but there's e5
wait a minute okay i have time bishop e2
queen e2 b5 king takes c5 here
so oh if here i castle queenside with
mates oh that's so beautiful
but the problem is white would play e5
there
um i still play this
if takes
i assume it's winning yeah it's gotta be
winning there
i mean there's a line where the king
goes here
and then i i
check here mate
it's too much fun okay let's do it
i do help the queen get in and this is
not like the
maybe the best practical move but i
think it's going to lead to the most
beautiful finish
there's at least one line where i castle
queensland with mate
uh please don't resign okay so now b5
wait a minute i was expecting queen digs
but i don't think there's much of a
difference
b5 king takes queen g5
and then there's three legal moves all
of which i'm pretty sure got mated by
force
so this would be the nicest please play
team d4
it's not every day you get to castle
queenside with mate
um and this is awesome nice line king c6
ah e5 okay e5 is uh
maybe the trickier of the lines so i can
play this
king has two legal moves
wait a minute did i miscalculate
no it's all good so if king takes c6 i
play queen e6
king c5 i mate king b5 will have a party
now the question
oh man the question is do i try and make
a work of art
and play f5
because f5 takes away the last square
and then i'm threatening casting
queenside with mate if white on
poissants
i still castle queenside with mates um
i don't think white can stop meat
i'm kind of playing with my food
but it's so delicious
okay f5 taking away the the e4 square
threatening maiden one
this doesn't help let's go
what a game oh it's so beautiful
it's so beautiful i can retire now right
ah but i didn't invest enough in my roth
ira
it's so beautiful 22 moves
casting queen side with me
can i tweet this let's tweet it
thank you bobo baggins i thought 1 000
bits
if i give 10 000 bit do i get a lesson
uh sure
yeah i can make that happen i i'd be
happy to just give a lesson
anyways but um
okay this game was one like big
i guess beautiful lesson of the staffer
gambit
i was thinking the other day i don't
really need more staff or gambit content
hello youtube but i want more stafford
gambit content
hello youtube yeah that was the first
game of the stream i started this game
before most people arrived in the chat
oh hash blew lichist's mind and now it
has to restart
oh yeah um can people oh people can't
quite see it
but lee chess yeah lee chase has to
restart that game was so beautiful
whoa it's bobo baggins okay let me know
when that can happen
oh yeah let's be in touch if you can
send me a whisper on twitch i can send
you um
we can set up a time
um thanks so much boba baggins and thank
you thank you normstrong
with a thousand bits and double pawns
with the 1400 bits
so that was um that actually transposed
into
like one of my favorite traps um
which i usually get from a different
move order usually white plays h3 here
if they're gonna walk into the trap and
then after queen d4 casting knight g4
it's a transposition um
oh we got it from a slightly different
move order
and i had shown this a few days ago uh
in a recent youtube upload
yeah so this game or this video on my
youtube channel
was uh the
it was a different line we could have
reached it was a new staffer gambit trap
where if white plays d3 there's queen f6
and then if queen e was a queen
i have to remember what i showed the
queen e1
no bishop f3 i showed and then there's
beautiful move
i'm so flustered i'm forgetting
forgetting the prep oh yeah queen e5 g3
takes takes here here and then here
and then it takes its uh its force mate
um but we went into and we went into
this line
and then and it was so much fun
i mean i had i had a simple made into
this this this
but um
[Music]
i feel like f5 if i was more artistic i
think it's still force mate
because the king's just so abandoned by
its pieces
yeah it's still mate and oh f5 is made
in three
okay there's a bunch of main entries
here
okay so uh that will go on youtube
if you're watching in the future on
youtube you can watch on twitch
you can subscribe just like ganzo 369
if you have amazon prime you can
subscribe for free
and watch this sort of thing in real
time
oh thanks everyone thank you retina
vault and
judo tasu solving with prime
oh i also made a high youtube emote
so if you subscribe you get access to
it's kind of small but it says hi
youtube
oh and thanks for the hype train i
appreciate it
yeah thanks everyone ki ori
and tech clocker
old something something
okay oh and it might be free thanks for
the 1000 bits
appreciate that
and double upon's gifting subs maybe
this will be the rest of the stream
just watching twitch shot and
fascination
and high to keep off the lights mom